the history of credit goes back to
50.
it's a rather a new phenomenon okay the
good news is all this credit has fueled
massive amounts of growth in the economy
but the bad news is it's come at a cost
and I and I saw it firsthand you know
like I said I did credit collections
from about 1991 up to about 2002.
um it comes at a cost a lot of people
have a lot of credit card debt and the
thing about credit card debt and credit
itself and radio mostly with credit
cards you know in this show although a
lot of this is applicable to things like
you know credit that you may borrow for
mortgage or for a business loan and
stuff like that but credit card debt
seems to have
um
the most issues if I can put it that way
so currently
and I've got a few notes here that I
took down before I created the show
earlier
470 billion car transactions happen per
year that's on
the Earth the entire planet
470 billion credit card transactions per
year but then to put that in perspective
there are less stars in the Milky Way
than there are credit card transaction
in a year
uh the average American has two credit
cards which I think is probably a little
bit low I think this data is a few years
old now
um I've got at least three or four I
think
um
so two sounds a little bit on a low side
uh there is currently 820
no sorry there's 930
billion in credit card debt
in the US right now and let's just put
that in perspective
I don't even know if my calculator will
go up that high
what's the population of the U.S right
now
you just damn phone it's probably user
and type of note I can do it with one
hand
what's the population of the United
States
so 331 million
okay be quiet
yeah this isn't going to work on this
calculator I don't have enough zeros
anyway the numbers are astronomical that
is a lot of debt per person
see if I can do it on the Google
Calculator here
come on calculator work with me
yeah we're talking 28 000 per per head
um so 1950
we went from a cash only economy in some
places there was layaway that was where
you would go
to a store my granddad used to tell me
the story he wanted to go get like a
sweater or something like that you go to
the store marks and Spencer in the UK
put down a quid go back the next week
when you got your next paycheck or two
weeks when your next paycheck came in
put another quid down and in a few weeks
when you paid it off whatever four or
five quit at the time they would they
would take the sweater home sort of
thing
in 1950 it changed with the Diners Club
Card the sky Frank McNamara was the guy
that invented the first credit card
apparently he was at a restaurant
foreign
and uh forgot his wallet and saw a need
he was a marketer as a businessman and
he saw a need for
um a credit issuing card
so in 1950 Diners Club card was invented
that's probably one of the oldest credit
cards well that is the oldest credit
card but he but he built it around
specifically restaurants hotels and
rental car companies were the first um
establishments to accept the Diners Club
card
in 1958 so eight years later later the
financial institutions caught wind of
this because so many of these uh diners
clubs cards were getting moved around
they saw an opportunity to make some
money the average
um
interest rate on a credit card according
to the stats that I pulled says 16 that
seems a little bit low in my estimation
um I think the data is probably stopping
around 2020 so we're 2023 right now
inflation's High interest rates are
higher
uh the rate of inflation is rather high
as well too I I would estimate the
average interest rate on a credit card
today is probably into the 20
28.8 is very common on retail store
cards here in Canada anyway so if you go
to uh Walmart Canadian Tire Best Buy
Home Depot any of those major Big Box
store chains I'll get to all these super
chats in a second by the way
um
your interest rate is going to be about
28.8 when you start going into the
higher risk loan areas where the bank
won't issue the credit to you in a line
of credit stuff like that
um 35 38 I think the
usury cost of borrowing is still just
under 60 percent in Canada so 59.9
percent
um payday loan companies start pushing
in start to push into those types of
territories
um so I don't trust the 16 that I saw
here because even when I was running my
debt business
the average consumer that was struggling
with credit card debt had quite a few
28.8 percent interest credit cards
so some of this some of these digits
here that I'm looking at seem a little
bit low in my experience
um 1958 Bank of America so at that time
this is interesting one in five never
paid back the credit card balance that
they were issued right
um
they started with a small Target
demographic and I think was Fresno
California then they went to the entire
State and then they went Nationwide uh
but Bank of America lost 9 million this
is in 1958 by the way issuing these cars
because one in five people weren't
paying them back
credit cards make money by the way
usually with an annual fee and a
merchant fee for the transaction
Merchant fees are usually a small
percentage
um some of the credit cards like Amex
for example tend to have the higher
Merchant fees
two three four five percent maybe the
other credit cards are usually like one
in change
again it all depends but that's how
they're making their money they're also
making most of their money now off of
um the interest rates and something that
I found interesting I was I was one of
those guys that when I was running my my
credit card debt relief business I would
I would start going down these different
rabbit holes because there was a
lobbying effort that I had to do for two
years on Bill 50 uh bill c-55 I think it
was called at the time around 2011 uh
for those of you that are Canadian Jack
meat saying was a critic on it and I sat
across the table from him many many
times wasn't impressed with any of the
politicians that I dealt with all a
bunch of garbage humans you know to be
truthfully in and honest at the end of
the day but
I did a lot when it came to infusing
myself in the very Fabric and the veins
of credit issue and practices
um they're predatory in my estimation
they they would strategically issue
credit cards to the youth because they
knew that you give a 21 year old a
credit card versus giving a 61 year old
a credit card the 21 year old is
probably going to be more irresponsible
with it because we love delayed sorry we
don't love delayed gratification anymore
we like instant gratification
and because the interest rates are so
high
they can have that 21 year old on the
hook for the rest of their life paying
interest versus a 61 year old which has
a much shorter lifespan so
a lot of the marketing strategies that
seem to Target
more of the youth
this is in the 90s and 2000s you know in
you know time after that this isn't what
was happening in 1958 they were they
were legitimately just passing out
credit cards because they saw it as a
good opportunity to increase profit
margins
um credit cards were then introduced in
Europe starting in London by Barclays
Bank in 1966
but it was marked as a status symbol to
the super rich so
the English have a different approach to
credit card debt so for example
in 2019 in the U.S
there's 930 billion dollars worth of
credit card debt outstanding but the
United Kingdom has less than 100 billion
in credit card debt granted it's a
smaller country but proportionately
it's it doesn't it doesn't align with
the amount of debt that's outstanding
I always found it interesting you know
how how cheap the English were always uh
considered they were always mocked for
being they used to call them stingy
um the Europeans that would come and
visit
the English or in or in England or to
immigrate into England especially if the
women started dating the men they used
to mock them and call them stingy and
stuff like that because they wouldn't
spend a lot of money they wouldn't turn
on the heat in the house so so in the
United Kingdom they have a different
philosophy when it comes to money like
it's like it's considered over there uh
shameful to have debt to some degree and
I think it seems to translate into
today's uh world because clearly the
amount of debt that's outstanding over
there's a lot less than what it is in
the United States
um get back to my notes over here
another thing I found interesting was
that
Studies have shown that people that so
if you have the choice between pulling
cash or your debit card out and buying
with what's in your bank account or
buying on credit and paying it back in
30 days
you'll spend up to 100 percent more than
paying with cash if you use credit
um McDonald's study this very very uh
closely and they determined that
55 percent more was spent at their
restaurants when people were encouraged
to use credit cards over over cash
so like like the psychology of of people
using credit
is insane MIT did a study that showed
there's a massive release in dopamine
when buying things with credit versus
cash
interesting that is eh
tonight's beverage is a uh it's a bone
broth I'm trying to increase my protein
intake so probably about 15 to 18 grams
of protein in the bone broth but it
actually tastes pretty good
so it's like a chicken spicy tide sort
of uh bone brothly mixing some
beef broth in there it's good stuff
anyway
so that's a little bit of the history of
uh credit card debt by the way China
so the United States says 930 billion
dollars worth of debt as of 2019 and
2019 China has 1.23 trillion dollars
worth of credit card debt Russia started
issuing credit cards
looks like in the 70s
um
they're used worldwide let's just let's
just call it what it is you know they're
used worldwide they're a very very
effective tool now
going back to what I was talking about
earlier I was one of those guys that
would you know I would deal with a
lobbying effort I would deal with the
creditors I would deal with the
collection agency I would audit uh calls
and I also did it on the other side of
the spectrum when I was running my
credit card debt relief Club because
rather than dealing with
credit card companies or student loans
or car loans or sundry items they they
collect on everything in collection
agencies one of the items that was that
was highly contested or like
seriously problematic for the banks at
one point I don't know if it still is
today if they still allow it or not but
they used to have these sundry items
and what this was is that you know when
you go to an ATM and you put your uh
paycheck in an envelope and you put it
in the bank and then you could make a
withdrawal for you know let's say that
check was for a thousand dollars and you
wanted to pull out two or three hundred
bucks
you could go and do that I've never done
that before but that was done a lot by
people except for what they would do is
they put empty envelopes into the ATM
and then they would make a withdrawal so
they never actually deposited a a check
or they would put in uh a fake check or
an unsigned check or just a piece of
paper sometimes in the envelope because
the envelopes had these little holes so
there was readers in the machine that
would try to like pick up that there was
something in the envelopes to try to
counter it with that so
there's all this like counter
Push Pull that's done with
credit card companies and credit issuers
and at the end of the day it never
really seems to cost them any money does
it right like I really hope you guys
enjoyed that clip if you want to watch
the full-length podcast you can find
that over here that clips from if you're
new to the channel make sure you hit
subscribe over here and pin down below
in the top comment you'll find a bunch
of useful links to my website my
supplement line books and a bunch of
other stuff have an amazing day peace
out